Congratulations on finishing lesson five. Here, we
took many of the basic techniques you learned
in previous lessons and extended them to
look at patterns across many variables at once.
>> We started with simple extensions to the scatter plot,
and plots of conditional summaries that you worked with in
lesson four, such as adding summaries for multiple groups. Then,
we tried some techniques for examining a large number of variables
at once, such as scatter-plot matrices and heat maps.
>> We also learned how to reshape data, moving from
broad data with one row per case, to aggregate data
with one row per combination of variables, and we moved
back and forth between long and wide formats for our data.
>> Next up in lesson six, we'll hear from our colleague
Solomon. He's going to do an in-depth analysis of the diamond
data set, so you can see how an expert does it. Lesson six also covers a larger
part of the data analysis process, highlighting the role
of EDA. Solomon did a lot of reading about
the diamond industry. He wrote codes to scrape
and format a new data set, and he used
the results of his exploratory data analysis to guide,
interpret, and evaluate a statistical model of diamond prices.